[موسيقى]
حياكم الله في حلقه جديده من برنامجكم
الندوه وصلونها اليوم يتحدث عن تصريح ملا
الدنيا وشغل الناس لرجل غاب قليلا عن
المشهد ثم عاد ولم يكن العود احمد الداعيه
الكويتي الاخواني وحينما اقول الاخواني
فلست بذلك انبزه بالالقاب بل هو فخور بذلك
ويعلنها على رؤوس الارشاد الداعيه الكويتي
طارق السويدان اثار الضجيج مؤخرا حينما
ذكر الحرم المكي مقارنه بالمسجد الاقصى ثم
قال حررهما بضمير التثنيه الله والضمير
عائد طبعا هنا او يشمل هنا الحرم المكي
عند هذه النقطه سار جدل كبير في الساحه
السعوديه وغير الساحه السعوديه حول حقيقه
مواقف
القياده الاخواني الكويتي طارق السويدان
ومن خلفه تنظيم الاخوان في العالم
الاسلامي من المملكه العربيه السعوديه
سنجعل هذه نقطه الانطلاق
ونفيض في النقاش لكن خطوط وخيوط ترتد الى
هذه النقطه المركزيه وشركنا في الندوه
اليوم هو الكاتب والباحث السعودي الاستاذ
عبد الله بن مجاد العتيبي حياك الله استاذ
عبد الله لماذا صرح طارق السويدان بهذا
التصريح مؤخرا بعد غياب عن المشهد لان هذا
هو ما يعتمل في نفوس جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين منذ سنوات طويله كان كانت
المملكه العربيه السعوديه دائما هدفا
لجماعه الاخوان المسلمين منذ المؤسس حسن
البنا وزياراته المتكرره للسعوديه
ومحاولاته لفتح فرع لجماعه الاخوان
المسلمين في السعوديه ورفض الملك عبد
العزيز رحمه الله
لهذه الرغبه حسب ما ذكره فؤاد شاكر في
كتابه
استمر هذا الحلم وتطور انهم يستهدفون على
الدوام الدوله السعوديه والمجتمع السعودي
والشعب السعودي لعده اسباب لان السعوديه
هي
مهبط الوحي وهي بلاد الحرمين وهي مارز
الايمان وهي
ايضا القدرات كثره الشعب السعودي ايضا
الملائه الماليه في الشعب السعودي قصه
طويله فهم دائما يحومون حول السعوديه
ويستهدفونها بخطاباتهم وفتاويهم ولذلك فهو
يعبر عن مكنون الاخوان المسلمين حينما
يقول حرر الله المسجد الحرام من الحكم
السعودي هذه ليست زله لسان هذه ليست خطا
عابرا هذا هذه هي عقيده اخوانيه راسخه
ولكنه صرح هذه المره بها
عمدا ام خطا هذه اخرى لكن ذلك لا ينقض ان
هذه الفكره اصيله ومتعمقه في خطاب الاخوان
المسلمين وغالب جماعه ربما تذكر ايضا
استاذ عبد الله بشبيهها او نسخه الاسلام
السياسي الشيعي فنعرف ان
الخميني ايات الله الخميني كما يعرف كان
من وصاياه تحرير الحرمين صحيح من السلطه
السعوديه فهنا نقطه تلاقي ايضا بين هذا
هاتين النسختين نقصد الاسلام السياسي
السني والاسلام السياسي الشيعي لكن اشرت
الى نقطه مهمه هي انهم يركزون على
السعوديه
ليس عفوا خاطر بل هذا امر مرسوم له ومخطط
له طارق السويدان حينما استعرضت وانه حضر
لهذه الحلقه طبعا ونعلم هذا الشيء لاننا
عايشناه لكن من باب تجديد الذاكره
وانعاشها
كان مركز كان يعني جل نشاط طارق السويدان
كان في الساحه السعوديه الغرف التجاريه
اتكلم طبعا فيما قبل الربيع العربي
الجامعات وجدت له يعني هو سيرته هو اللي
كتبها على سبيل الاحتفاء في الشرقيه في
جده في الرياض في الشمال في الجنوب في
الجامعات يتحدث في التاريخ يتحدث في تطوير
الذات يتحدث كم ظاهره هلا يعني
ذاكره المشاهدين والمجتمعين كيف كان الحال
فيما قبل الربيع العربي كيف كان نشاط
الاخوان منهم طارق السويدان في الساحه
السعوديه وما هي تكتيكاتهم نعم كان في
الساحه السعوديه للنشاط
الاسلام السياسي او النشاط الصحوي بشكل
عام منتشر في كل مكان ومتغلغل في كل مكان
سواء في المؤسسات الحكوميه في المؤسسات
الخاصه في الانشطه الثقافيه في الانشطه
الدينيه في غيرها وكان العمل عمل منظم
فكانوا يملاون كل الانشطه في البلاد
ويرتبونها وينظمونها والدعم المالي
والتغطيه
السياسيه او الامنيه او
طارق السويدان كغيره من عشرات النماذج كان
يسير في هذا السياق وكان يسير في هذا
المنحه
يعني كانوا من الذي اختلف فيه طارق
السويدان واضرابه وامثاله عن المشايخ اللي
نعرفهم العاديين
ليش اعتبروا شيء جديد يعني الا اعتبروا
لانهم هو نوع من الخطاب الجديد في
الخطابات الاسلام السياسي كانوا يعرف باسم
الدعاه الجدد الدعاه الجدد يستخدمون
اساليب وطرق ليست معهوده
لدى الفقهاء التقليديين فهم اول
امرهم يعني يتقصدون السياسه في كل طرحهم
ويحومون حول السياسه الامر الاخر انهم
بداوا يقراون في علوم جديده
علوم الانال بي وعلوم التطوير الذات وعلوم
صنع القيادات وعلوم
مختلفه ويطبقونها فيما يطرحون من امثال
سلمان العوده وسفر الحوالي ثم جاء بعدهم
طارق السويدان وعمر خالد
وعده نماذج وامثله اخرى وهم هكذا الذي
يقرا تاريخ هذه الجماعات يعرف انها تطور
نفسها في كل مرحله بما يتوائم معها واليوم
ايضا لديهم اليات جديده وافكار جديده
لتطوير طروحاتهم لتتوائم مع المرحله طيب
لقائل لن يقول عبد الله انه هذا ليش ما
تعتبرونه دلال دليل دليل ونجاح لهم بمعنى
انهم اناس يملكون الموهبه يملكون الحضور
يملكون التخطيط يملكون التنظيم وبالتالي
يملكون القدره على التجدد بدليل انهم يعني
خلقوا مضامين جديده ومحتوى جديد غير
المحتوى التقليدي للوعظه التقليدي الذي
يقوم بعد صلاه العشاء او بعد قبيل صلاه
العشاء او بعد صلاه العصر ويلقم الرياضه
الصالحين للنووي بضعه احاديث وصلى الله
وبارك هؤلاء اناس لديهم القدره ترى طارق
السويدان مهندس بترول متخرج عنده ماج
الدكتوراه مهندس بترول انا هذه يعني كانت
ملفته للنظر ايضا تخصصه في كل مراحل
التعليميه العليا كان في هندسه البترول مع
ذلك الرجل استطاع ان يخترق المجتمع لو لم
يكن ناجحا لم استقبله الناس بهذا الامر هل
هذا التصور صحيح ام ثمت عوامل اخرى في
تقديرك هو ما في شك انهم قدموا خطابا
جديدا لانهم ليسوا فقراء تقليديين لا
علاقه لا لكثير منهم بالفقه التقليدي ولكن
الشعار الاسلام هو شعار سياسي يستخدمونه
للوصول الى اهدافهم واهدافهم صريحه سيطره
على الحكم الوصول الى السلطه بالسلم
بالقوه بالثورات بالقتال بالعنف لا يختلف
طارق السويدان عن اسامه بن لادن لا يختلف
حسن البنا عن البغدادي الخلاف بينهم فقط
في الاساليب او التكتيكات المتبعه للوصول
الى هذا الهدف هذه جماعات عنيفه تستبيح كل
شيء تستبيح الدماء وتستبيح الاموال
وتستبيح الاعراض لل الى هدفها كونهم
يستخدمون اساليب حديثه هل نعتبر خالد شيخ
محمد
عبقريا لانه عرف كيف يضرب الابراج في
امريكا ويقتل المئات ولم يستخدموا العنف
يعني طارق السودان لا لا يعني
قصدي عشان نستحضر لو كان ثمه احد من مريدي
طارق ربما رد بهذه الطريقه يعني السويدان
لم يستخدم العنف ربما فيه او لسياسه
مرحليه
يتغياها وهذه جماعات عرفت ان تفرق بين
تنظيمات السريه والتنظيمات العلنيه بين
الخطاب المعلن والخطاب السري ولكن طارق
السويدان وغيره في لحظه كاشفه تاريخيه وهي
لحظه الربيع العربي كشف عن ما تخبئه نفسه
نسي كثيرا من طروحاته في التطوير الذاتي
او فيما يسميه هو التغيير عند هذه النقطه
انا لفت انتباهي حين المسند برامجه
التلفزيونيه واللي كانت منتشره الى تسعه
كان عنده عده برامج ولكن من اشهرها برنامج
علمتني الحياه من 2011 الى 2012 صنع
برنامجا جديدا في قناه الرساله وغيرها كان
اسمه ازمنه التغيير يعني هنا في تحول ملفت
للنظر يعني من تطوير ذاتي الى ازمنه
التغيير يعني هو قوات السويدان مره بعده
مراحل في البدايه دخل المشهد
كراوي للتاريخ
وخذ يتناول
التاريخ طبعا باسلوب
ركيك علميا وحتى ركيك لغويا لانه قدرات
الشخص في العلميه متواضعه هل اقصى علميه
التراثيه طبعا وهو الذي طرح فيه طرحه
وتحدث فيه يعني لا نريد ان نتحدث عن تخصصي
في البترول لكن نتحدث عن الشان العام الذي
دخل فيه فاخذ يتحدث عن
الفتنه الكبرى بين الصحابه ويتحدث
في هذا الاطار ويفصل باسلوب الدعاه الجدد
في في العالم العربي المستقى من الدعاه
الجدد في الغرب
فجذب الكثير من الناس لعده اسباب منها انه
عقيده اهل السنه والجماعه والمسلمين الا
يتحدثون فيما شجر بين الصحابه هو الرجل
ذهب وتحدث وتحدث
بجهل عجيب وغريب يعني ليس بالاحداث
التاريخيه
وبالمواقف لا يمتلك ادنى قدره على التحقيق
والتمحيص التاريخي بل انه يخطئ في اسماء
الاعلام يعلى بن اميه يسميه يعلي وليس
لديه احد يعني يصحح له هذا الخطا ولذلك
قبلت محاضراته في بدايه التسعينات تقريبا
باستهجان كبير من قبل التيارات السلفيه
وتيار اهل الحديث اللي كان منتشر ومتفشي
في تلك الفتره بينما قامت كل جماعات
الاسلام السياسي ورموزه وتياراته وهي
تنظيمات قويه بدعمه بدون استثناء
ومنحوه الانتشار الذي وصل اليه عند هذه
النقطه
نحاول ايضا نسلط الضوء لكن بعد فاصل وجيز
على تاريخ نقد الصحوه الان اخذنا طارق
عينه يعني او كان نموذج او كمثال لانه نجم
ماذا عن السياق الذي او ادبيات نقد الصحه
ولنتحدث عن الساحه السعودي لكن استمعك في
فاصل سريع فاصل لا تذهب بعيدا ما بعد
الفاصل يستحق اجتماعكم
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في برنامجكم الندوه
تصريحات طارق السودان التي دعا فيها الى
تحرير الحرم المكي من هو طارق ما هو سياقه
كيف جاء لماذا مهتم بالسعوديه اخوانيته عن
هذا الامر كان شريكنا في الندوه الاستاذ
عبد الله بن مجاد العتيبي الباحث والكاتب
السعودي يتحدث قبل الفاصل لديه بقيه من
حديث ثم سنفضي الى محور اخر تفضل استاذ
عبد انا اريد ان اقول ان طارق السويدان
كغيره ولكنه ابرز نفسه كداعيه
لتطوير الذات وداعيه يستخدم علوم الارنب
وغيرها في مرحله الثانيه ثم تكشف مع
الربيع العربي كشر عن انيابه وابانا عن
حجم التلون والتناقض الذي كان يعيش فيه
بين خطابه المعلن والمضمر في خطابك كشف عن
كل شيء نحن اليوم نتذكر ومع الاحداث
الداميه للاسف في السودان والصراع العسكري
الدامي في السودان انه قبل سنوات قليله
كان يذهب الى هناك ويحاضر في الاخوان
المسلمين ويحاضر في التيارات الاسلاميه
التي كانت تدعى الى الخرطوم في ظل النظام
الاصولي وكان ينظر لنشر الخراب والدمار
والفوضى والقتل وتخريب البلدان بحسب
عبارات طارق سويدان نفسه في البلدان
العربيه في السودان وفي مصر وفي اليمن وفي
سوريا وفي غيرها كان لا يستبعد ان يقتل
عشرات الالاف
بدعم منه بتوجيه من هذا الذي اعلنه وهذا
الذي قاله فضلا عما يدار في الاقبيه
السريه لجماعات الاسلام السياسي والتي
طارق السويدان يطرح نفسه كقائد وعضو فيها
في اكثر من بلد ولذلك هو اضطر مجبرا للصمت
في الفتره الاخيره حتى يعيد انتاج نفسه
ولكنه يعني وقع في سيء اعماله حينما كان
خروجه في التهجم على المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وعلى الحرمين الشريفين ولذلك ليس
غريبا على طارق السويدان وهو متسق مع
خطابه وخطاب الصحوه الاسلاميه عند انا لفت
انتباهي موضوع انه صمت الفتره اللي راحت
كانهم يعني فهمتهم كلام من كلامك عبد الله
انه يريد الظهور بمظهر جديد وهذا الامر لا
يخص طارق يا بدولي يعني كانها تكتيك عام
او خطه عامه لاعاده التمظهر من جديد اما
نفس الاسماء القديمه لكن تعود نفسها بثوب
جديد او بعناوين جديده او ابراز اسماء
جديده لا ادري هل انا مصيب في هذا الامر
ام لا
والامر لكن دعنا نسمع جوابك على هذا الامر
ثم بتحدث عن تاريخ نقد الصحوه في السعوديه
هل تتفق معي او تختلف نعم انا اتفق في هذه
النقطه الخطاب الصحوي اليوم تلون بعده
الوان هو تلون على مسيرته وتغير على
مسيرته وهذه قصه طويله لكن اليوم الطروحات
الحويه بدات تزيد من تلوناتها ومن
تغيراتها لتتوائم مع الانظمه السياسيه مع
التوجهات الجديده في العالم العربي ككل
وفي السعوديه ايضا يعني نحن جزء من هذا
العالم
وهذه الجماعه لديها خبره قويه انها في
لحظات الانتباه لها وملاحقتها ومحاصرتها
تتلون بالوان متعدده وتغير التكتيكاتها بل
تغير خطابها فنحن نلاحظ ان هناك تغير في
الخطاب وفي المفاهيم التي تطرح رايناها في
الربيع العربي بدل ما كانوا يطرحون
الحاكميه والجاهليه في الربيع العربي
يطرحون العداله والمساواه والديمقراطيه
والثوره اليوم يطرحون المفاهيم الجديده في
العالم من التطوير الذاتي
البودكاست هذه على تلك على مستوى المفاهيم
وهذه على مستوى الوسائل ترى كل كاسيت
وذهبوا الى البودكاست تركوا الكتب وذهبوا
الى المدونات
نزل المستوى ما يسمى باللهجه السعوديه
البثوث هذه البث المباشر الى البثوث في
تويتر وفي غيره لغه الخطاب تغيرت ولكن
المضامين والافكار واحده والهدف والغايه
واحده التغلغل في الدوله ونحن عندنا في
السعوديه تجربه صريحه منذ نهايه الخمسينات
وبدايه الستينات كيف تغلغلوا في المجتمع
وفي المؤسسات هم يصنعون الشيء ذاته اليوم
ولكن باساليب مختلفه وبطرائق مختلفه كما
يجري في غير السعوديه من البلدان
هل يحق لي طرحه ولا يعتبر يمكن شاطح شوي
ممكن واحد
يتفق مع اجنده طارق السويدان السياسيه
والاجتماعيه ما عدا بين قوسين العداء
للدوله السعوديه ما عدا العداء للدوله
السعوديه هذه يختلف ويختلف بعنف مع طارق
السودان بس في بقيه الامور الاجتماعيه
والثقافيه ورؤيه العالم ورؤيه السياسه
ربما يتفق مع طارق يعني هل ممكن اقرا لشخص
شيء بهذا المعنى ولا نشاط احد ولا شيء هذا
الاصل الاصل في خطابات جماعات الاسلام
السياسي انها متفقه على معاداه الانظمه
السياسيه ومن معادات الانظمه السياسيه
العداء الاكبر يتوجه للسعوديه لكن هناك
تيارات لا تختلف مع جماعه الاخوان او مع
القاعده الا في مساله تكفير الدوله
السعوديه او تكفير الانظمه الحاكم ثم
التكفير اقصد فيه في يعني شخصيات او ثقافه
مو تكفير الا الدفاع الشرس عن الدوله
السعوديه وعن الحكم السعودي في مقابل من
ينتقص او يتهجم منه لكن انا
ولذلك موقفه من الترفيه موقفه من العلاقات
لا
موقفهم
من عن موقف هؤلاء يعني ولذلك انا اقول لك
ان خطاب التشدد وخطاب التطرف في اصله واحد
والخلاف على مساله الحكم اللي ذكرت انت
بعض تفاصيلها وخلافهم في مساله واحده اما
بقيه المسائل فالاتفاق والاشتراك قائم بين
جميع المتطرفين وهو مخترق للجماعات يعني
الاخواني يتفق في موضوع المراه
مع السرور يتفق مع
القاعدي يتفق مع الداعشي يتفق هم متفقون
على اختلاف تياراتهم وان بدا بينهم بعض
العداء على مسائل التطرف والتشدد التي من
مظاهرها الترفيه والسياحه
وبناء اقتصاديات جديده في الانفتاح في
البلدان هذا هم يتفقون جميعا لكن ايضا لان
نفس التكتيكات الصحويه واحده ومتعديه
ومتجاوزه للجماعات
يحسنون اخفاء هذا او ابرازه اذا ذهبوا لل
نعم المحور اللي كنت اعد الكرام به نقد
الصحوه تاريخ نقد الصحوه في السعوديه
البعض ينادي العام تويتر وما تويتر انه
والله احنا اللي نقود المعركه ولا في
السناب شات ولا في تويتر ولا في غيرها من
منصات السوشيال ميديا في حين انه نتحدث
مثلا عن طارق السويدان ترى الان حسب تقرير
اللي طال عمره 69 عام فالرجل نشيط يعني من
فتره طويله من عقود يعني وبالتالي المعركه
قديمه هذا ما اريد قوله من هم رواد معركه
نقد الصحوه ومجابهه الصحوه في السعوديه
نعم في السعوديه لا شك ان هذا نقد الصحوه
هو عمل تراكمي قام به الاشخاص مختلفون عبر
فترات زمنيه مختلفه في البدايات هناك
شخصيتين اساسيتين في نقد الصحوه المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
رحمه الله الوزير السفير والوزير والكاتب
والشاعر وهو من هو
نقد الصحوه مبكرا ودخل في صدام تاريخه مع
الصحوه في بدايه التسعينات الميلاديه ايضا
الكاتب الكبير والاستاذ تركي الحمد استطاع
ان يواجه هذه الصحوه علنا وان يقدم نقد
لها في المرحله نقدر نسميها الاولى من نقد
الصحي اللي هي بدايه التسعينات نهايه
الثمانينات وبدايه التسعينيات اذا غاز
القصيبي اترك الحمد هم الرواد اي نعم هم
الرواد ما في شك في نهايه التسعينيات
وبدايه العقد الجديد من الالفيه الجديده
تشكل ضمن السياق السعودي تيار كان يسمى
بتيار تنوير الاسلامي هذا التيار قدم نقد
علمي ومؤسس ومتواصل ومنهجي لتيارات الصحوه
الاسلاميه لخطابها ومفاهيمها وادواتها
واساليبها
بدايه الالفيه الجديده وسبب اثر في
السعودي في الصوالين وفي الندوات ثم انتقل
هذا الى وسائل الاعلام وخرج هذا الخطاب
للعلن والصدام وكان تاريخيا
وموثقرشات على صفحات الصحف في القنوات
واستمر الى اليوم هذا التيار خرجت منه
تفرعات ومواجهات مختلفه ولكنه استمر واخذ
زخما ماذا عن لقده الصحة اليوم
يرفعون اللواء نقد الصحوه اليوم للاسف
صارت الدعوه يعني اقرب الى التشخيص اقرب
الى التزين منها الى النقد الحقيقي
الصحوه ولله الحمد رؤيه
سمو الامير محمد ولي العهد السعودي واضحه
وجليه
وخطاباته وتصريحاته واضحه وجليه ان هذه
مرحله يجب القضاء عليها ويجب نسميه اليوم
هو الرائد الجديد
دعني اقول لك هناك اناس كثير اليوم يدعون
هناك ناس كثير وتيارات تدعي انها قضت على
الصحوه ودمرت والصحوه اقوى منهم مليون مره
هؤلاء خرجوا على السطح في مع السوشيال
ميديا ويعتقدون انهم حينما يكتبون
يعني اشياء بسيطه هنا وهناك في بضعه اشهر
انهم قضوا على الصحوه هذا غير صحيح الذي
يعلق قضاء على الصحوه في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه هو شخص واحد فقط لا غير هو سم
ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
برؤيته وحزمه
وادراكه لهذا الخطر اللي تشكل هذا بقيه
التيارات والنقد الذي يطرح عليهم
اما ان يكون نقد سطحي
ساذج يتعلق بالمظاهر فقط ايضا هناك تيار
ينقض الصحوه وهو يدعي انها انتهت وقضي
عليها من باب المجامله للقياده السياسيه
او للدوله ولكن هو في الباطن يدافع عنها
علمها ام لم يعلم هو لا يريد ان يضغط على
الصحوه لتنتهي حقيقه يريد ان يريد ان يسكت
عنها بانه تم القضاء اي نعم حتى تستمر
وهناك نقد هادف موضوعي عميق
يتناول تاريخه ويتناول مبادئها وافكارها
ويقرا مستقبلها ويحاول ان يوجد طريق
الحديث لا يمل استاذ عبد الله لكن من
الجزئيه الاخيره اثرتها كاني افهم انك
تدعو الى المزيد والمزيد من اثراء هذا
الحقل وهذه الادبيات نتحول الى حقل علمي
وفكري فلربما تتسنى الفرص ايضا بالمناسبات
اخرى او من زوايا اخرى او في محطات اخرى
ايضا لتقليب هذه الفكره على كل اوجهها
اشكرك غايه الشكر استاذ عبد الله مجاد
العتيبي الكاتب والباحث السعودي واشكركم
على متابعه هذه الحلقه التي كنا نحاول ان
نفهم فيها مغزى ودلالات تصريحات القياده
الكويتي الاخوان لطارق السويدان ومقارنتها
بتاريخ نقد الصحوه في السعوديه
فحياكم الله وبياكم مجددا والى لقاء جديد
[موسيقى]